do you have any plans to visit the
border
at some point you know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole this whole
this whole thing about the border we've
been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border
and i haven't been to europe
maybe you should get out more princess
laughing pants
it's funny because she laughs and she's
wearing pants
[Applause]
so
well that didn't end well i speak of
cat's night out
last night
[Applause]
[Music]
oh she leaves a wake of damaged
furniture and tears
but i also speak of actress ellie kemper
folding
to the woke here's a recap from the most
handsome man
on television ellie kemper star of the
office
and unbreakable kimmy schmidt is under
attack after online idiots declared
she was a racist her crime in 1999 a st
louis business group named her their
queen
of love and beauty the group used to be
a whites only but integrated 20 years
before she won her crown
20 years it's hard to
absorb the news when it's coming from
someone that gorgeous
[Laughter]
now when we did the segment uh we
saluted kemper for not responding to the
twitter mob
calling for her scalp no offense
elizabeth warren
but that's how you beat cancer culture
you realize it's just a dozen losers
screaming for attention from a
content-starved media
like newborn babies you let them scream
until they scream themselves out that's
what my mom did to me
in the woods we thought kemper would
outlast the mob kind of like katie
pavlich powering through a hangover
but sadly just days later kemper
groveled to the woke police
offering not just an apology but a
confession one so pathetic
it embarrassed john cena or senna
i warned you i know i know it had all
the woke
catchphrases and i quote i unequivocally
deplore denounce and reject white
supremacy at the same time i acknowledge
that because of my race and my privilege
i am the beneficiary of a system that
dispense unequal justice and unequal
rewards
pows speak more off the cuff than that
but she follows the script there is a
very natural temptation when you become
the subject of internet criticism
to tell yourself that your detractors
are getting it all wrong
but i realize that a lot of the forces
behind the criticism
are forces that i've spent my life
supporting and agreeing with
did jane fonda write this she then said
she was grateful for her humiliation
and tells us that she will use her
privilege in support of the better
society
i think we're capable of becoming well
how nauseating of her
so what if we all followed her lead
every single person playing pro baseball
has to apologize for participating in a
league that once segregated blacks
and that also includes baseball fans
baseball cap wearers and anyone who's
ever tried to get to second base on a
date
also every democrat must apologize and
demand a name change for their political
party
it was the party of slavery and jim crow
after all
they fought a war to keep slaves joe
biden even gave a eulogy for a democrat
leader
robert byrd who was a kkk cleagle or
grand poobah or whatever those idiots
call each other
so think about this kemper was a
debutant for an
organization one she didn't know was
racist
even before she was born but every
single democrat
became a democrat knowing they were once
the party of slavery
as people often say to me in the sauna
wow that can't be right
i never know what gets a laugh these
days i understand kemper she's terrified
of being ostracized
like most actors they desperately want
to be liked and they can't speak
unless they have a script and a
consultant without that they're
vulnerable to the worst kind of
groupthink
i wonder what the angry white male has
to say
[Music]
oh i'm not worried i can't be canceled
my mainstream career was destroyed years
ago when i met a man named greg gutfeld
thanks greg
[Applause]
you're welcome tom his career is over
how about the angry black male
[Music]
so
so somebody got apologized for something
that happened long before they were born
and when they joined they don't do that
anymore
well i guess with that kind of thinking
i guess democrats are on the clan
so that was kemper's time in the barrel
it began with an old photo and it became
a twitter trend in fact if you look at
any mob action
it always starts that way with something
called twitter trends
they show you what people are clicking
on at the site which then becomes an
attention self generator
much like chris cuomo remember
uncle tim that smear on senator tim
scott without twitter trends
no one would have heard of it the
covington kid smear was a twitter trend
manipulated by the legacy media promoted
with a dishonestly
edited clip and then there's trump
feeding the fish
mike pence loading empty boxes trump
wearing his pants backwards
twitter trends created these fake
stories it's pornhub for leftists
and like the wuhan lab all you need to
do is create one source and unleash it
twitter trends does the rest because
that's the media's trough
trends are the easiest stories to write
and they play upon outrage addicts
who have no lives my theory if jack
dorsey eliminated twitter trends today
cancel culture would starve to death and
the world would instantly become a
better place
so jack it's not hours of fasting and
meditation or that stupid amish chin
that's going to make you a better person
it's removing the part of your sight
that destroys lives
but until you do that jack we shall sit
by and watch the endless parade of
cowardice
dressed up as enlightenment while
twitter feeds on the cadavers of careers
and the contrition will all be an act
sadly it's the best acting some of these
celebrities do
yes he's so
sharp wasps worry about lawrence kudlow
stings
former director of the national economic
council and joseph kudlow
on fox
[Music]
when she left arizona the temperature
dropped 20 degrees
townhole.com editor and foster's
contributor katie pablo
she's like a praying mantis skinny
bright and may kill
and eat her husband [ __ ] his contributor
tattoo
and finally his watch fan will make an
excellent belt
my massive sidekick and host i've got
set on foundation
tyrus
lawrence you've been a white guy for a
while
what
um what do you think of all this woke
stuff do you think it was
right for her to apologize no i don't
think she should have apologized i don't
think she had any idea
when she was 19 years old in saint louis
from some deb party
yeah what where when how yeah he had no
idea
exactly she's just being woked by the
twitter mob that's
all she is yeah i mean when i was a
debutant i had no idea i didn't like
i didn't look up the past you know
racist abuses of the people that made me
a debutant
granted it was all on craigslist about
three weeks ago
greg your biggest biggest problem with
the debutant was the dress that you
decided to wear
the fashion choices that you decided
those pictures will hopefully never come
out
well ooh speaking of pictures that never
come out
katie i mean have you ever done anything
on instagram
on instagram that's public greg really
do we have anything from her
instagram that we can show to our public
what is that katie this has got to be
canceled
you're letting a dog eat a baby you are
letting a dog eat filming it and filming
it you're filming it
yeah this is fake news he was actually
saving
the baby this is a baby that is used to
teach cpr
and he was alerting us that the baby may
need saving
that's what he was doing oh boy do i
have egg on
go to jail but he's too cute to cancel
here yes so what do you make of this uh
um
is she now safe from cancellation i
think she's safe because she's a
democrat
and if you're a democrat as you noted in
your monologue you can
give eulogies at funerals for kkk
members and
fellow democrats you can basically do
whatever you want as long as you
acknowledge it and then
say that you have white privilege and
try to move on so she'll be fine yeah
you know tyrus when we did this original
story
you were so proud of her you said that
because she wasn't going to respond
and then what did she do she betrayed
you tyrus well no
she didn't betray me and before we go
there i've warned you about the cena
stuff
i've warned you but you're just a big
man aren't you gut phil you're just a
big man
before this show's over tonight i'm
gonna show y'all how big he really is
but
i digress i'm
going to channel my inner white woman
okay
and i'm going to give white america
some advice yes the next time someone
tells you you have
white privilege or you should be ashamed
do what we do i'm here because i worked
my ass off
i became a comedian because i worked
hard i studied i went to college i
auditioned
kiss my ass if you want my spot come get
it i'm not just gonna come give it to
you
the color of my skin has nothing to do
with it
actually but every time said you only
got this job because you're black i'm
like
black ain't crack near a joke on this
show i did that
yeah so start fighting back with facts
and not apologizing
for something you have absolutely
nothing to do with you know i really
love that
yeah i just love that but i'm sitting
here it's the first time we've been on
stage together
i'm basically scared to death
don't worry he's going to kill me before
he comes we're not quite there yet
america but we're close
we're close yes when i'm in the alley
you go
big hard on my chest downward i promise
you have a big heart on your chest and
you stop yes no no you're not
you i told you about the scene i'm
getting you for this [ __ ]
what if i didn't write that joke what if
i blame it on one of our writers no
i know tom i know cat you guys just
sterling gene play with crayons
[Laughter]
so kat um here's an interesting fact i
learned today do you know that twitter
trends are based on really small numbers
anywhere from 1200 to 1900 tweets
over a six hour period can get a twitter
trending
that's nothing i can't listen to stuff
with numbers in it
it makes my brain scramble that's why i
got married uh he can do the taxes
um i i had a huge problem with her
apology i will say that think about this
all day
the part where she said she did not know
that it was elitist
yes like bro it was a ball you know
normal 19 year olds we didn't go to we
went you know not to
the ball we went to like dollar pitcher
night and hope they didn't check ids
and like it's not like she just realized
oh i was rich like she's
she was grew up incredibly rich her
great-grandfather
started you know with what's been called
the dynasty of
bankers early yeah i that's so this is
what i was googling she wasn't just rich
she was super but there was a museum
named after her grandma
really yes don't just don't act like you
had no idea you know you
didn't you never got you never ellen you
never got strep throat in the mcdonald's
play place like the rest of us
that's true how dare she be born into a
rich family
what was she thinking she said she
didn't know the
rich lady ball she went to was elitist
there i'm saying no
i bet you didn't cancel the museum now
thanks to you
because you let them know what larry how
can she
possibly know as some 19 year old kid
going to this deb party
how can she know anything about this
right and why
30 years later i have her old shoes it's
an ex boyfriend this is my theory
ex-boyfriend is is was has been holding
on to this picture forever because
that's what i would do
but this is the worst guilt trip i have
ever seen yeah yeah yeah the absolute
worst
and what you are so right about that why
be proud of it have a good time
you know what i mean just go out there
and dance and go to balls and have
debutante parties we did the same thing
here
back east big deal you're making
progress larry oh yeah
let's keep it real i didn't know i was
poor until i got to college like why
don't you have two tvs on top of each
other i didn't know
i didn't know it was short until i got
to high
i'll school you later tonight
everybody's mean tonight hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else